let's talk a little bit now about moving
on from in general my goal in in 2020
let's talk about the 2020 election and
what my approach is going to be because
we're quickly getting into the 2020
election in earnest and this is going to
be I believe an uglier election than we
have maybe ever seen in the modern
political era I'll tell you how and why
that's going to manifest the let's set
it up
it's January 2nd the first votes in the
Democratic primary are coming up in just
a month we have debate number 7 for the
Democratic candidates in a couple of
weeks Donald Trump is increasingly
starting to campaign for re-election in
a serious manner as serious as he does
it this is going to be an ugly election
in ways that may differ from past
ugliness so think back to the Clinton
days there was an attempt pretty late in
the 20 and the 1992 election to attack
Bill Clinton by publicizing a supposed
black love child that Bill Clinton had
if you watch the documentary the war
room which is an excellent documentary
you see Bill Clinton's advisors at the
time James Carville strategists advisers
advisers James Carville and George
Stephanopoulos deal with this possible
smear about Bill Clinton with a black
love child in real time and that was
very ugly in its own way in the 22 2008
campaign the extreme racism that we saw
against Barack Obama so there has been
ugly nough Steen was very ugly in its
own way but if you thought that the
Hillary has Parkinson's conspiracy
theories were ugly if you thought Trump
making fun of how candidates look was
ugly if you thought Trump attacking
megyn kelly about a bloody you know what
was ugly just wait until the 2020
election ramps up there's a really good
piece by a conservative Jonah Goldberg
in the Los Angeles Times about this and
even if you don't agree with Jonah
Goldberg's politics or his analysis of
candidates which I don't
he astutely points out that Donald Trump
in 2016 had nothing to lose he didn't
think he was going to be the nominee he
was already planning on what
once he lost the nomination how to
capitalize on maybe coming in a
respectable second or third place Donald
Trump is now the incumbent and even if
he didn't want this thing to begin with
he does not want to lose and he is an
impeached president which is driving him
absolutely up a wall we'll talk about
that a little bit later being president
does not at all seem to have matured
Donald Trump if anything he's more
childish and unhinged than ever and then
you add to this a bunch of different
things add to this that he has this
fragile cognitive state in which he
finds himself or an emotional imbalance
or whatever it is something there adds
on to the 2016 Trump that we saw add to
this that in 2016 Donald Trump did not
have the right-wing media supporting him
all along remember that they eventually
came to support Donald Trump but early
in the 2016 Republican primary really
even in 2015 Fox News was not with
Donald Trump a lot of that right-wing
apparatus that now basically is with
Trump at least for now they were not
with him in 2016 so he has the benefit
of that which means he will be able to
get away with even more knowing that
that right wing media apparatus is going
to defend him now that may change I said
it's possible Fox would abandon Trump in
2020 hypothetically it doesn't seem like
it's going to happen unless that changes
we expect that this support is going to
continue this will further enable Donald
Trump add to that Donald Trump's
friendship with tabloid propagandist
David pepper-pecker rather which gives
Trump more resources and wherewithal to
publish and push really horrible attacks
on whoever is the eventual Democratic
nominee over my vacation last week I had
the opportunity to read almost all of
Ronin Pharaohs book catch and kill and
that is another recipe for a campaign
that will reach levels of ugly that we
have not seen before in his piece Jonah
Goldberg is already citing two early
examples of the type of campaign that
this will be saying quote first on
Friday night the president retweeted and
then deleted a post naming the
whistleblower in the Ukraine affair
if candidate Trump had done something
like that criticism from the right would
have been deafening then on Sunday night
at an event in Milford New Hampshire the
famously tactile Biden was greeted by a
handful of protesters don't touch kids
you pervert one man who claimed not to
be a trump supporter shouted a woman
started a brief chant of quid pro Joe if
you live in a swing state it is going to
be even extra kooky crazy ugly in 2020
if you live in a red state a lot of that
ugliness is probably already infected
like a virus many of your friends and
neighbors and you're already in the
thick of it and probably have been for
the last year or a year and a half one
thing I'm looking at doing for myself
for my own sanity and I know that some
people have noticed this I've gotten
emails from people saying David I'm
seeing you sort of pull back on social
media I'm looking at how much more can I
pull back on social media without losing
touch with the audience without losing
touch with you know the usefulness of
those tools to an end of independent
media show like this one because it's
just too toxic and I know lots of you
have been feeling this for a while I
talked about this with Joe Rogan last
June when I was on his program let me
know what you think let me know what you
were planning on doing when it comes to
it's not just the ugliness that we're
expecting but it's also the even bigger
effect of these algorithmic echo
chambers that are created and
perpetuated on social media I want to
hear from you a leave a reply if you're
watching on youtube send me a tweet at
de Pakman otherwise and make sure to
follow both at de Pakman and david
pakman show on Twitter I want to hear
from you we'll probably follow up
tomorrow or early next week about this